[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro de dimanche en politique en
direct sur france 3 bourgogne
un mois après le 78e congrès du parti
socialiste et à la veille de la
traditionnelle ascension du mont beuvray
par les amis d'arnaud montebourg
quel avenir pour le ps au niveau
national et dans ces anciens fiefs de
bourgogne la ligne politique reste flou
et le positionnement d'olivier fort
nouveau premier secrétaire n'est pas
perçu clairement par l'opinion
aujourd'hui inaudible le parti de
françois hollande n'a pas profité du
virage à droite du quinquennat macron
qui semble plutôt servir jean luc
mélenchon le ps at-il encore un avenir
y at il un espace politique entre macro
et mélenchon avec quelle ligne et quel
leader pour l'incarner on en débat ce
matin avec mes invités tous membres du
parti socialiste ayant d'ailleurs des
fonctions au niveau national jérôme
durain bonjour je vous êtes sénateur de
saône et loire vous avez apporté votre
soutien à olivier faur lors du dernier
congrès du ps mais je rappelle aussi que
vous êtes un proche d'arnaud montebourg
alors avant de donner la parole aux
autres invités
être socialiste aujourd'hui sous l'ère
macron ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
continuer le travail du parti socialiste
depuis son origine c'est promouvoir la
justice sociale permettre l'émancipation
des individus essayer de développer les
territoires pas tout ce que ne fait pas
macron quoi aussi anne marie godard
bonjour bonjour vous êtes vice
présidente de la région bourgogne
franche comté vous avez été nommé
secrétaire national du parti socialiste
par olivier faur c'est donc lui que vous
défendiez lors du congrès qu'est-ce que
ça aide socialiste pour vous aujourd'hui
en 2018
aujourd'hui être socialiste c'est
d'abord être humble c'est faire preuve
d'humilité parce que dernières élections
c'est 6%
donc nous sommes humbles et puissent y
être profondément déterminé déterminés à
travailler autrement et à travailler
ensemble
c'est à dire que vous avez manqué
d'humilité par le passé notamment sur le
quinquennat hollande c'est parce que
j'ai dit je dis qu'aujourd'hui en tout
cas on est humble voilà c'est l'humilité
c'est de la détermination et c'est la
volonté de travailler ensemble pour pour
projeter pour se projeter et pour
avancer surtout denis lamard bonjour
bonjour vous êtes conseiller régional de
bourgogne
franche comté vous avez soutenu vous
emmanuel maurel l'ailé gauche du parti a
au congrès du ps
vous êtes également un proche d'arnaud
montebourg être socialiste aujourd'hui
encore une fois après un an de
présidence macron ça veut dire quoi je
crois qu'être socialiste aujourd'hui
c'est ne pas oublier qui on est et d'où
on vient pour qui on se bat nous sommes
le parti de l'abolition de la peine de
mort de l'invention des congés payés des
conventions collectives qui protège les
salariés
c'est notre rôle de protéger les gens
les plus modestes
il ne faut pas l'oublier selon vous et
ça veut sans doute dire que pendant le
quinquennat de françois hollande on a un
peu oublié
on va en parler certainement entonnoir
bonjour bonjour vous êtes premier
secrétaire de la section ps de dijon
vous vous avez soutenu stéphane le foll
au congrès du ps janvier vous êtes le
légitimiste de la table être socialiste
aujourd'hui ça veut dire quoi être
socialiste aujourd'hui c'est se battre
pour les gens qui gagne 1200 1300 euros
par mois voilà c'est se bat pour ses
millions de salariés qui aujourd'hui
rencontrent des difficultés dans leur
quotidien c'est se battre dans les
collectivités locales comme au niveau
national pour essayer d'améliorer le
quotidien de ces gens et puis c'est
s'opposer aussi à la politique du
gouvernement notamment à ce président
des riches qui est emmanuel macron merci
à tous les cas d'avoir accepté cette
invitation en direct ce dimanche vous
qui nous regarde et vous pouvez bien sûr
commentée sur les réseaux sociaux cette
émission et les propos de nos invités
avec le hashtag dean paul bourgogne
alors est ce que c'est a encore un sens
dans ce monde des manuels macron d'être
socialiste est ce que finalement il
laisse encore de la place océane scharre
godard vous qui représentez finalement
la direction du ps autour de cette table
est ce que ça encore un sens et quel
sens vous allez bien pouvoir lui donner
sachant que emmanuel macron laisse assez
peu d espaces à ses adversaires il faut
bien le dire quand c'est vrai qu'il
prend beaucoup de place mais il y a un
espace pour le parti socialiste entre
mélenchon entre macron il y à un espace
pour le parti socialiste
emmanuel macron avait promis un nouveau
monde
on a plutôt une nouvelle droite donc on
voit très clairement qu'aujourd'hui le
parti socialiste à un espace maintenant
il faut lui laisser aussi un petit peu
de temps et c'est vraiment ce que je
voudrais dire parce que au regard du du
titre que reste-t-il du parti socialiste
on voit bien je sais que c'est très en
vogue tels vite d'être très réactif mais
les
c'est un petit peu de temps parti
socialiste m olivier faure a été élu
premier secrétaire il y à un mois et
demi à peu près on a eu deux bureaux
nationaux de secrétariat nationaux donc
la direction est en train de se mettre
en place
le travail est déjà à commencer
maintenant il faut réactiver aussi le
travail dans les sections avec les
militants les élus sont sur les
territoires aussi on en parle on en
parle pas assez mais parti socialiste
sont aussi des élus qui travaillent au
quotidien dans les collectivités
regarder à dijon tout ce qui se passe
regardez la région bourgogne franche
comté vous avez là trois élus régionaux
autour de la table donc voilà il y à
l'innovation dans les territoires des
expérimentations qui sont menées il ya
de l'énergie mais laisser un petit peu
de temps aussi au parti socialiste pour
récupérer tout à l'heure je parlais
d'humilité 6% dernières élections du
travail tels que c'est en train de se
remettre en place mais en un mois et
demi j'avais pas fait avancer pas faire
mais personne ne sait faire la bourgogne
a longtemps été un fief socialiste il ya
beaucoup de départements qui ont été
dirigées par les socialistes la nièvre
je pense évidemment la nièvre de
françois mitterrand mais aussi à la
saône-et-loire d'arnaud montebourg il ya
deux représentants de saône et loire sur
sur ce plateau
aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est du passé
cette étiquette socialiste en bourgogne
jérôme durain est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment que nous appartenons au passé
l'aïe a plutôt un plateau qui est assez
jeune les gens qui sont très motivés et
vous êtes un des rares parlementaires
qui reste au parti socialiste brésilien
a pas beaucoup ça mais non on appris
d'une réalité on a on a pris une
déculottée l'année dernière c'est juste
est ce que pour autant nos bases
politiques dans les idées et
dans la population disparu je crois pas
enfin il ya quand même des gens qui sont
motivés dans les sections moi je côtoie
beaucoup d'élus qui sont attachés à ce
qu'on fait ce qu'on porte
et puis on revient quand même du
maquereau nisme le nouveau monde fait-il
toujours aussi envie on a compris que
c'était la recentralisation que c'était
uniquement pro business entre noirot
parler de la présidence des riches mais
c'est exactement ça j'ai remarqué que
les français n'ont pas la même
perception dans les enquêtes d'opinion
emmanuel macron reste quand même
agréable un an de présidence le
président des derniers qu'on ait eue qui
a le plus la cote si je suis au fait les
français ça ça mériterait d'être nuancée
par rapport à la durée dans le monde à
paris les chiffres sont pacsés island
mandat que nous ne saurions voir
françois hollande ou nicolas sarkozy la
cote était moins importante chez les
chiffres que nous ne soyons pas nous en
bonne position c'est normal on est en
reconstruction
donc il n'y a pas d'alternative pour
l'instant est l'alternative c'est avec
nous qu'elle se construira parce que
nous sommes sans trop à gauche entre
mélenchon et d'autres forces centristes
qui ont été abusés par le maquereau
nisme je crois que notre devoir revenir
vous croyez oui bon il compris certains
socialistes qui se disait
sociaux-démocrates qui est qui j'ai
marqué à la place de certains de nos
collègues qui sont partis chez makro et
qu'ils doivent assumer une politique en
terre d'asile qui est un peu compliqué
un petit fiscale qui est très
désavantageuse pour les classes
populaires
une recentralisation comme on l'a jamais
connue les politiques sont menées
d'ailleurs par des anciens socialistes
pour la plupart à je pense à gérard
collomb sur la loisy l'immigration avec
la côte conseil dans l'opinion
donc je suis présidente d'un croisé bien
fait celle du président mais voilà on
vous parlait de la région denis lamard
vous êtes l'un des organisateurs je vous
remercie d'autant plus de venir ici
parce que vous avez certainement de
chose à faire aujourd'hui à la veille de
l'ascension du mont beuvray l'un des
organisateurs avec jérôme durain et
d'autre de l'ascension du mont beuvray
traditionnel rendez vous des amis
d'arnaud montebourg depuis depuis 2004
est ce que ça représente encore quelque
chose que le parti socialiste en
bourgogne mais déjà vous répondez à la
question en la posant puisque vous nous
invitez quatre socialistes à débattre
pendant une demi heure c'est donc vous
même vous y accordez de l'importance et
que c'est une force qui est ainsi
présidentielle est encore un an donc
effectivement se pose des questions sur
son état de santé
bon bah écoutez on va plutôt bien
regarder les sourires que l'on affiche
aujourd'hui tous les matins alors
peut-être revenons au mont beuvray
puisque c'était la question vous plaît
au départ c'est vrai quand on a pris nos
baskets pour monter le mont beuvray la
première fois c'était en 2004
juste après la période de canicule et le
gouvernement raffarin qui avait décidé
de supprimer le lundi de pentecôte c'est
pour ça que nous avons fait cette
manifestation à l'origine
aujourd'hui vous poser la question du
sens c'est de votre prestation a bien
entendu un sens puisque on nous parle de
nous supprimer une deuxième journée de
solidarité au nom de quoi alors que par
ailleurs on vient de faire des cadeaux
fiscaux énorme en supprimant l'idf à
toute une partie de la quête de la
population qui elle n'a pas à mettre la
main à la poche pour nos personnes âgées
regardez dans les maisons de retraite ce
qui se passe là le lundi de pentecôte a
été fait pour alimenter la cns à la
caisse nationale de solidarité pour
l'autonomie dans laquelle d'ailleurs le
gouvernement a pris 100 millions au mois
de novembre dernier pour équilibrer les
comptes généraux et on voudrait ono des
cadeaux fiscaux à nous les salariés les
travailleurs de ce pays leur demander de
faire des efforts supplémentaires c'est
ça qu'on veut dire quand on relâche dans
les ehpad et cetera quand on va le
vieillissement de la population la
question de la dépendance qui est
toujours pas réglé on se dit qu'il va
bien falloir trouver l'argent quelque
part la dépendance le gouvernement
sarkozy avait déjà fait l'étude
l'étude du cinquième risque hollande a
fait la même chose le cinquième risque
ça vaut 5 milliards d'euros 5 milliards
d'euros on règle la question de la
dépendance pour nos parents et puis nous
quand on sera nous mêmes en maison de
retraite
pendant ce temps là on ne veut pas
régler le problème de la dépendance et
on vient donner 4 milliards 2 de cadeaux
fiscaux dits sf
alors qu'on aurait pu très bien en une
seule décision régler cette situation
dans les étoiles vous ne dites pas de
deuxième jour de solidarité
ah non non non non pas de deuxième
rétablissement de lier ce f pour les
personnes âgées
arnaud montebourg sera là demain parce
que la question se pose et la dernière
fois que j'ai eu au téléphone pour en
parler j'ai pas eu l'impression que la
réponse était très clair l'année
dernière ils devaient pas venir il est
venu au dernier moment et là pour
l'instant on devrait produits qu'ils
étaient sur d'autres sentiers belle
formule mais ça devrait bombe à la
question dans tous les cas nous sommes
des bébés montebourg
jérôme avec d'autres s'il n'est pas là
ces idées seront là d'ailleurs ces idées
sont sur la table vous ne répondez pas
ma question
on sait toujours pas s'il viendra ou le
sentier il sera pas avec nous demain
mais peu importe le flambeau doit pas
rester dans la poussière nous on est là
et où tous les cas c'est les thèmes qui
l'a porté depuis toutes ces années sont
sur la table
on reviendra à ces questions et à
l'incarnation de ce projet socialiste
dans quelques instants
océane scharre et godard on parlait des
fiefs il ya un des fiefs depuis quelques
années c'est c'est la région la région
aujourd'hui est présidé par marie-guite
dufay vous en êtes une vice présidente
est ce que marie-guite dufay
elle a toujours sa carte du parti
socialiste actuellement elle a soutenu
emmanuel macron à l'élection
présidentielle est ce que c'est bien
clair est-ce que la région est
socialiste
la région est socialiste on vous le
confirme
quand on met en place et quand on milite
et qu'on mène des actions
autour de la pour la culture pour
l'emploi la formation en priorité des
femmes et des hommes sur les territoires
qui sont éloignés de l'emploi pas ou peu
qualifiés
la transition énergétique aussi fait
partie nos piliers
oui nous sommes socialistes nous sommes
de gauche taz est défait à sa carte au
parti socialiste
donc non je ne sais pas pourquoi je
serais jamais parce qu'elle a soutenu
emmanuel macron pendant la campagne de
l'élection présidentielle viennent
peut-être plus denis lamard ou jérôme
durain m'écouter nous moi je suis
président du groupe majoritaire à la
région je sais que c'est une majorité de
gauche qui attachés à des valeurs de
gauche qui conduit une politique de
gauche et vous allez voir dans les
prochaines semaines que les marqueurs de
gauche vont être présents dans notre
action régionale on cherche à s'adapter
au contexte institutionnel qui est très
difficile pour les régions je parlais de
recentralisation et les menaces qui
pèsent sur les compétences qu'on exerce
sont extrêmement fortes dans notre
combat c'est pas entre nous pour savoir
qui est plus à gauche ou qui l'est moins
c'est plutôt de savoir comment on
continue à porter nos politiques de
gauche avec un contraintes nationales
une contrainte de l'état contraint de
recentralisation qui nous accable mais
ne vous inquiétez pas la région à gauche
d'europe plus de bisbilles entre vous
sur qui a appelé à voter macron capable
ça ne gène pas quand même un peu de
nyama non mais la vraie question c'est
qu'on ait été élu ensemble sur un
programme pour un projet elle a évoqué
est notoire dit si certains sont un peu
ma chronique est ce qui compte c'est qui
on applique ce qu'on a dit
alors vous avez été ce qu'on l'a promis
voilà c'est là dessus qu'on doit être
jugé et qu'on doit se juger entre nous
d'ailleurs
moi pour moi c'est ce qui compte en
effet pas de langue de bois là non on a
on a un projet qui est clair pour les
bobines aux francs comtois
je pense que les habitants commencent à
voir quand même ce qui se passe sur la
culture
on est une des premières régions de
france aussi offensive sur le domaine de
la culture sur le vivre ensemble sur la
formation des demandeurs d'emploi vous
allez voir ce qui va se passer sur les
transports scolaires
à chaque fois la majorité régionale a
des engagements elle va jusqu'au bout de
ses voyages il faut savoir quand les
élus respectent ce pourquoi ils ont été
élus vous nous dites oui mais ce qui
aurait des bisbilles puis quand les élus
respectent pas ce pourquoi ils ont été
élus vous dit c'est pas bien vous faites
pas ce que sera votre programme là en
l'occurrence à la région le programme
il est mis en place et c'est ce qui
compte le programme contrat il ya un
contrat clair avec les électeurs
non il ya un monde fou que les rallyes
je vous ai tous les quatre sur la table
et vous mais s'est dit tiens une autre
politique pour nous parler de la
socialiser à une occurrence je ne lis
pas la question il ya une autre
politique possible que celle d' emmanuel
macron et vous travailler au quotidien
avec des gens qui ont soutenu emmanuel
macron gates bonne et que pour les les
grands programmes devant les électeurs
qui a été décidé de choisi par les
électeurs en 2015 en décembre 2015
les élus régionaux font leur programme
c'est la même chose à la mairie de dijon
à la mairie de dijon les électeurs ont
choisi l'équipe de françois rebsamen en
c'est vrai que l'équipe de françois
rebsamen l'équipe de françois rebsamen
rassembler la majorité de françois
rebsamen met en oeuvre le programme est
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que c'est une
majorité rassemblée et ceux qui ont été
élus en 2015 qui aujourd'hui s'en vont
mais c'est là pour le coup là il ya du
prix avec les skis je vous pose la
question c'est qu'on a un peu
l'impression qu emmanuel macron a comme
atomisé le parti socialiste d'ailleurs
chez les républicains c'est pas mal non
plus mais est ce que notamment pour vous
la frange des hollandais historique
landais story qui sera là son parti
certains mais c'est leur choix et
aujourd'hui je pense que j'aurais pas
être vulgaire mais je pense qu'ils sont
henri doivent être vraiment cocu parce
que quand on voit ce que fait emmanuel
macron aujourd'hui qui pour le coup
vraiment fait une politique en direction
des riches
une politique pro business aux
entreprises qui est là uniquement pour
redistribuer des richesses
vous avez vu le rapport aux d'oxfam qui
est sorti la semaine dernière je me suis
élevé cette semaine j'ai fait un
communiqué de presse sur ce sujet parce
que je trouve ça absolument scandaleux
que dans notre pays
quasiment trois quarts des bénéfices des
entreprises soient distribués aux
actionnaires et seulement 5% aux
salariés ça c'est inadmissible quand la
richesse elle est créée elle doit
profiter à ceux qui créent cette
richesse c'est à dire les salariés
si on fait de la politique c'est pour ça
si on fait de la politique
c'est pour améliorer le quotidien des
gens les quotidiens des gens qui se
battent qui sont sur le territoire qui
vivent c'est ça faire de la sodida faire
ce que fait emmanuel nasrallah aurait de
l'argent des français ou est ce que les
français
eh bien on aura envie d'une autre
politique salle est menée par emmanuel
macron il ya une bêtise au foyer qui est
qui est sans doute enfin qui passe pour
être en tous les cas plus moderne c'est
c'est comme ça que les maquereaux nist
veulent veulent faire voir les choses
quel est votre point de vue jérôme
durain je pense parce que je les ai
vécus comme parlementaire comme élu mais
comme mes collègues qui a eu beaucoup
d'arrogance dans cette revendication du
nouveau monde d'ailleurs on l'a senti au
sein du groupe en marche à l'assemblée
nationale avec le sentiment qu'il n'y
avait rien avant nous arrivons ces
vierges de toute politique publique
c'est parfois très insultant pour tous
ceux qui ont travaillé l'action publique
l'intérêt général il s'inscrit dans la
continuité et cette façon de dire il n'y
avait rien avant moi c'est d'une
prétention inouïe
je sais ça rejoint d'ailleurs un peu le
comportement du président de la
république sur la scène internationale
où finalement dans une gourmandise
narcissique il va rendre hommage à trump
avec des conséquences géopolitiques qui
sont catastrophiques donc pour revenir
au parti socialiste moi j'étais au
groupe du sénat cette semaine on a posé
deux questions au gouvernement
une sur oxfam une sur les territoires la
ligne est claire il n'ya les terres
c'est comme on aide les gens sur le
terrain et comment les aides contre un
système capitaliste qui est totalement
fou deuxième exemple hier avant-hier
devant l' agence régionale de santé
des élus de la majorité régionale avec
les collectifs qui se bat contre le
programme régional de santé oms n'a pas
revendiqué d'aller prendre la parole
d'ailleurs monsieur odoul outils du
front national a essayé il s'est fait
chahuter
nous on est restés là en soutien aux
gens qui se battent parce que c'est
notre travail de défendre les
territoires c'est notre travail de
défendre les salariés
c'est notre travail de défense du
service public sauf que quand vous dites
emmanuel macron on a l'impression qu'ils
avaient rien avant lui
vous avez fait partie les uns et les
autres dans vos débats internes au parti
socialiste des gens qui ont des
construire la politique de françois
hollande qui l'ont critiqué
j'aimerais savoir finalement à qui la
faute est-ce que c'est macron qui est
aujourd'hui emmanuel macron qui met en
difficulté le parti socialiste est ce
que c'est le quinquennal françois
hollande
sans refaire le match
mais où est ce que ce sont un peu les
frondeurs denis lamard est ce que vous
regrettez pas certaine certains choix
oui bien sûr en 2012 regardez où on en
était on avait tous l'elysée le sénat
l'assemblée nationale
nous avons ajouté des départements les
municipalités on aurait pu en profiter
pour faire un peu plus de redistribution
on aurait dû faire de la redistribution
d'ailleurs le rapport oxame si on a
parlé est là pour nous le rappeler
les travailleurs de ce pays travaillent
pour produire des richesses et non
récolte pas leur part vous avez péché
par trop de réalisme dans tous les cas
françois hollande parce qu'on est moins
mal que les frondeurs était là pour
rappeler qu'il y avait une ligne celle
du bourget c'est le programme de
françois hollande qui n'a pas été pour
moi appliqués en totalité du quinquennat
le quinquennat il porte quand même ses
fruits n'importe quand même ses fruits
aujourd'hui on voit d'ailleurs les
entreprises félicite se félicite aussi
d'une forme de reprise elles embauchent
à nouveau elles ont des besoins
ça reprend on le voit on le voit on
entend donc je pense qu'il faut pas non
plus être uniquement dans la dans la
critique négative par rapport aux cancun
quinquennat le parti socialiste si les
ados c'est aussi à ce quinquennat
emmanuel macron récoltent aussi les
fruits du quinquennat précédent
voilà donc mais bon je le rappelle
encore enfin bon sauf que sauf que je
voudrais aussi revenir sur ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure sur le fait que
les français sont plutôt satisfaits de
la politique d' emmanuel macron il ya un
sondage qui a paru début mai qui précise
bien qu'il y a 72% des français qui
jugent comme étant injuste la politique
économique des manuels may cry donc oui
quand on parle de ligne du parti
socialiste le parti socialiste fait plus
pour ceux qui ont moins
oui nous l'affirmons nous travaillons en
ce sens nous soutenons et ça a été dit
par mes collègues tout à l'heure et nous
ne soutenons pas l'injustice je
l'envoyais pousser vos collègues blessés
selon le cas et c'est les débats de la
gauche mais vous savez quand on augmente
et les nuits
minima sociaux on a permis à un million
de personnes supplémentaires de
bénéficier de la cmu à la garantie gep
c'est ça le problème c'est qu'on l'a pas
dit puisqu'il ya une chose qu'il faut
dire aussi c'est que la situation
économique en 2012 ce n'est pas la
situation économique de 2017
on arrive il ya 5 % de déficit on a une
croissance qui est à zéro à la fin du
quinquennat
on a une croissance en 2010 est qu' à
2,2 pour cent et on a un déficit qui en
dessous des 3% donc la situation
économique n'est pas la même françois
hollande il aurait aimé redistribuer
plus mais il fallait d'abord déjà
redresser l'économie du pays et il a
redistribué à la fin de quinquennat et
aujourd'hui ce qui est scandaleux c'est
de voir emmanuel macron qu'il
redistribue une part de ça mais qui leur
est distribué uniquement aux riches
c'est le président des riches et des
très riches et françois hollande il a
une petite phrase dans son livre qui est
extrêmement intéressante parce que il
fait la litanie de toutes les avancées
sociales du goût du dernier quinquennat
il termine en disant j'attends
sereinement la comparaison
et ben oui moi aussi j'attends
sereinement la comparaison entre ce que
la gauche fait quand elle est au pouvoir
pour améliorer le quotidien des gens on
le voit dans les collectivités ou au
niveau national et puis ce que va faire
ce gouvernement alors on va parler de la
vigne dans un instant puisqu'on est sur
françois hollande répond si je comptais
vous poser la question un peu plus tard
mais est est ce que ce retour avec ce
livre etc
ça représente quelque chose pour voix
pour vous c'est une mise au point
jérôme durain denis lama ou où il peut
être un recours par moments des siens
contre les circonstances politiques font
que françois hollande n'a pas présenté
de bilan français il est parti d'autres
se sont présentés pour le parti
socialiste
donc dans la prairie je sais qu'on
connaît avec le succès qu'on connaît
lorsqu'ils sont pas descendus place
qu'ils ont pas descendu le bilan donc
aujourd'hui françois hollande finalement
ils bénéficient d'une forme
d'effritement de la cote d' emmanuel
macron moi je ne pense pas que françois
hollande soit le recours personne n'y
pense
en l'état actuel olivier faur propose la
renaissance il faut un cadre nouveau et
me olivier faure il à vos amis aux
calendes grecques la question du bilan
du quinquennat
est ce qu'il faudrait pas des badauds
sûr qu'on se ça mais on se reconstruit
on va faire valider par la population va
parler de méthode
macron c'est verticale c'est ultra
jacobins c'est techno c'est
l'aristocratie d'état olivier faure est
dit on va falloir des conventions va
inviter nos sympathisants à venir voter
sur des sur des éléments d'une in
politics avec le premier juge elle sur
l'europe
on y arrive l'alizé néolithique c'est
quoi ces social libéral
c'est plus à gauche vous même vous
n'êtes pas tous d'accord avec cette
question l'art début de cette émission
quand vous nous avez posé la question de
savoir pourquoi est-ce qu'on était
socialiste et qu'est ce qu'être
socialiste on vous a donné la ligne du
parti socialiste c'est à dire défendre
les gens qui ont besoin d'être défendue
c'est les gens qui gagne 1200 1300 euros
par mois c'est ça être socialiste c'est
ça la ligne du parti socialiste a
forcément été très clair dans le
précédent quinquennat pour tout le monde
mais moi je trouve qu'avec toutes les
mesures de redistribution qui ont été
faites à la fin du quinquennat louis a
eu des erreurs 2016 c'est une année
tragique la déchéance de nationalité est
évidemment c'est tragique mais ça c'est
manuel c'est cette impression
c'est tellement facile à sion qu'on
donnait aux pattes mais pourtant
détaillé de fallait redresser l'économie
est aujourd'hui l'économie allait
adresser donc redistribuées et 9ème et
battons-nous contre la politique de ce
gouvernement paye la main moi je je
trouve qu'à une forme de trahison qui
est vécu par les électeurs du parti
socialite par rapport au discours de
bourges est un peu trompé sur la
marchandise alors je suis d'accord avec
le timing est peut-être qu'il fallait
d'abord redresser ensuite redistribué
mais ses deux faces de redistribution
elle n'arrive pas eu lieu
et puis elle elle est fait à l'envers
par par le robin des riches qui est
emmanuel macron donc on a à regagner la
confiance de nos électeurs on a beau
dire on est là pour les les gens les
plus modestes qu'ils nous croient
aujourd'hui vous savez quand la
confiance est rompue dans un couple on
le connaît c'est compliqué de 2,2 de la
reconstruire il faut des actes aussi
bien que s'accordent à dire que les
mesures mises en avant en tous les cas
par le gouvernement des manuels macron
ressemblent plutôt à des mesures de
droite en majorité il ya aussi quelques
mesures qui ont été piqués dans les
idées de la gauche mais est ce que ce
virage un peu à droite n'aurait pas pu
plus vous servir et finalement vous
restez inaudible on entend surtout jean
luc mélenchon le meilleur exemple pour
regagner la confiance c'est ce qu'on
fait dans les collectivités
quand dans les collectivités locales
quant à la mairie de dijon ont fait une
tarification proportionnelle aux revenus
dans la restauration scolaire
quand on garde la semaine de quatre
jours et demi dans les écoles pour la
réussite des enfants quand on rénove des
ehpad ça c'est concret voilà ça c'est
une politique qui est menée par des
socialistes mais le décoder nationale
c'est celui jean-michel la crédibilité
de la crédibilité elle se fait d'abord
par les actes jean luc mélenchon il a
pas d'acte apport avoir été sénateur
pendant trente ans sur le dos du parti
socialiste c'est son seul acte politique
il n'a pas dirigé il a jamais été en
responsabilité
nous au moins on peut être crédible par
rapport au poney qu'on entend de plus
jean luc mélenchon des yamaha moi j'aime
bien
jean luc mélenchon mais je ne m'étonne
qu'à moitié oui mais j'ai quand même
l'impression que avec macro ils sont un
peu vous savez dans le dessin animé bip
bip et coyote son cours après ils ont
besoin l'un de l'autre pour se rattraper
et c'est un peu ça jean luc mélenchon
emmanuel macron on a besoin de le faire
exister
donc pour moi c'est un peu de la
politique spectacle il ya aussi toutes
les mobilisations dans la rue depuis des
semaines la sncf les personnels de santé
les étudiants et c'est pareil vous
capitalisez pas vraiment océane scharre
agoda sur ces mobilisations d'ailleurs
certaines vous êtes tout juste les
bienvenus le 22 mai vous serez peut-être
tous les quatre dans la rue mais le 26
c'est pas gagné le 22 mai effectivement
le parti socialiste sera sera un
mobilisés mais ça veut dire quoi de
capitaliser qu'est ce que vous entendez
par là à gré un petit peu agrégé un
petit peu les oppositions à emmanuel
macron pour vous permettre aussi
d'exister dans le discours mais c'est ce
qu'on vous disait tout à l'heure il faut
faire parvenir un tout petit peu patient
le 22 mai le parti socialiste sera dans
dans la rue aux côtés voilà des autres
mouvements
le premier secrétaire olivier faure va
contacter et à proposer en tout cas de
rencontrer les autres partis de gauche
comme nous d'ailleurs à force d'attendre
les gens force d'attendre que vous vous
remettiez ans c'est là que ça fait un
mois et demi à moi jamais un an qu'il ya
des ennemis ça fait un peu de qualité
fort et avait déjà eu des élections ça
serve as vite ça fait un mois et demi
qu'il y a et vous savez que les
françaises sont impatients il ya un
élément important que je vous laisserai
réagir évidemment il ya un élément
important ce sont les prochaines
échéances électorales et notamment les
municipales où vous êtes très très
attendus en 2020
puisque il ya encore un terreau d'élus
et vous en parlait il ya quelques
instants terreau d'élus du parti
socialiste c'est peut-être là que vous
tenez votre revanche
oui gérant du rhin je fold damas le
sujet c'est pas une revanche c'est pas
une question personnelle c'est pas une
question d'ego c'est une question
d'utilité pour le pays d'intérêt général
et de conception de l'histoire du pays
ça peut passer par là ça peut passer par
l'international mais il va y avoir les
européennes alors les européens il
faudrait que vous soyez d'accord sur la
ligne
on est en train de s'y mettre juste pour
terminer sur cette question emmanuel
macron il est tout seul il est tout seul
avec une espèce de roppe idéalisé
l'europe l'europe l'europe qu'est ce
qu'il ya derrière nous en train de
construire un projet une ligne politique
j'étais au bureau national
la dernière fois et tout le monde était
quasiment d'accord autour de la table
sur ce qu'on est en train de faire donc
on va avoir aux européennes une campagne
sur des sur une ligne claire vous êtes
d'accord sur la ligne sont là des
batteries à ce que je voudrais c'est
lancer un appel
profitez de votre plateau pour lancer un
appel 68 sont regardés en 10 secondes
j'aimerais qu'olivier fort sur notre
tête de liste pour les futures élections
européennes je pense que c'est un autre
premier secrétaire de porter la voix des
socialistes
les gens aiment les leaders n'aime pas
les suiveurs et donc le leader ça doit
être lié fort demain mais à écouter
aussi entre godard fera monter la
demande merci à tous les cadres d'avoir
participé à cette émission suivra de
près les évolutions de la ligne est
l'incarnation du parti socialiste arnaud
montebourg un retour opposera sans doute
la question demain dans nos éditions
d'information merci d'avoir accepté de
répondre à ces questions et d'avoir été
en direct ce matin merci à vous de nous
avoir suivis dans un instant le point
sur l'actualité régionale avec arnaud le
frère et la partie nationale de dimanche
en politique francis le tenir au sur le
député fn gilbert collard très bon
dimanche
[Musique]